[Music]
if you listen carefully enough
the past whispers to you
we're here to see our dumbledore
that would be my brother
the world as we know it is coming undone
grindelwald's pulling it apart with hate
if we're to defeat him you'll have to
trust me
[Music]
this is the team that's going to take
down the most dangerous wizard in over a
century
a major zoologist his indispensable
assistant
wizard descended from a very old family
the school teacher
and
a mughal dumbledore should i give you
something
are you kidding me right now who
wouldn't like our chances
[Music]
off to save the world are we
things are not quite what they appear
[Music]
swivel but delicately i'm swiveling out
you're traveling
[Music]
yeah our wall with the knuckles
begin
today
what is this place the room we require
[Music]
correct three points to hufflepuff
[Music]
[Applause]
very dangerous forgotten wrong hands
mess you up where did you get it
i got for christmas
[Music]
foreign